>> Lawrence: I'M LAWRENCE JONES
IN NEW YORK TONIGHT DEMOCRATS
CHANCES OF HOLDING TON POWER ARE
LOOKING MORE AND MORE BLEAK AS
THEY RECORD NUMBER OF IMMIGRANTS
FLOOD THROUGH OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
STILL TRYING TO CONVINCE US THAT
THEY HAVE THIS UNDER CONTROL.
ON THURSDAY, DHS SECRETARY
MAYORKAS ACKNOWLEDGED THE SURGE
BUT DEFENDED THE ADMINISTRATION
HANDLING OF IT.
WATCH.
>> WE MEET CHALLENGES.
WE MEET DIFFICULT ONES.
WE DO SO WITH OUR HEROIC
WORKFORCE.
OUR EXPERTISE, OUR PLANS AND OUR
EXECUTION OF OUR PLANS.
HERE AGAIN, JUST AS WE DID WITH
THE CHALLENGE OF UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR,
WE HAVE A PLAN.
WE ARE EXECUTING OUR PLAN, AND
THAT TAKES TIME.
>> Lawrence: SO THAT'S WHAT THE
SECRETARY SAID IN PUBLIC.
BUT FOX NEWS HAS OBTAINED LEAKED
AUDIO OF WHAT THE SECRETARY IS
SAYING IN PRIVATE.
AND IT PAINTS A DRASTICALLY
DIFFERENT PICTURE.
WATCH.
>> A COUPLE DAYS AGO I WAS DOWN
IN MEXICO OMEXICO AND I SAID
LOOK, YOU KNOW, IF OUR BORDER IS
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE WE ARE
GOING TO LOSE, THIS IS
UNSUSTAINABLE.
WE CAN'T CONTINUE LIKE THIS.
OUR PENAL IN THE FIELD CAN'T
CONTINUE AND OUR SYSTEM ISN'T
BUILT FOR IT.
>> Lawrence: HE SAID WE ARE
GOING TO LOSE, IT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE BORDER.
THOSE WORDS CAN BE WILL TO THE
EVERY PART OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
CRIME IS SPIKING.
INFLATION.
OFFICIALS IN AFGHANISTAN ARE
CENTRAL BLING TO LEAVE AS THE
TALIBAN TAKES BACK THE COUNTRY
IN LIGHTNING SPEED.
YOU CAN CALL THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION A COMEDY OF
ERRORS BUT NOBODY IS REALLY
LAUGHING.
IT WOULD BE GREAT IF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD JUST BE
UPFRONT WITH US.
ADMIT THAT THEY ARE FAILING.
WE NORTH AS DUMB AS THEY THINK
WE ARE.
AMERICA CAN SEE THE REACH FOR
THE CRISES BROUGHT ON OUR
COUNTRY.
A POLL SHOWS MOST DISPROVE OF
BIDEN'S PERFORMANCE ON THE
ECONOMY, CRIME AND IMMIGRATION.
IF BIDEN DOESN'T TURN THINGS
AROUND SOON, HE WON'T JUST BE
LOSING THE BORDER, HE WILL BE
LOSING THE COUNTRY TOO.
JOINING ME NOW STEPHEN MILLER
WHO IS FILING A LAWSUIT AGAINST
THE DHS TODAY.
HE IS THE FOUNDER OF AMERICA
FIRST LEGAL AND LARA LOGAN MOST
OF LARA LOGAN HAS NO AGENDA ON
FOX NATION.
LARA, I WANT TO GO TO YOU FIRST
AND STEVE, I'M GOING TO GET TO
YOU ON THE POLITICS.
LARA, I WANT YOU TO TAKE ME TO
THE BORDER.
TELL ME ABOUT THE NUMBERS.
WHAT'S THE CURRENT STATE?
YOU HAVE DONE A LOT OF REPORTING
THERE.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING ON THE
GROUND?
>> WELL, WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
EVERYONE WHO IS ON THE GROUND IS
THAT THEY ARE BREAKING RECORDS
EVERY SINGLE DAY IN TWO SHIFTS.
IN ONE STATION ON THE BORDER IN
STARK COUNTY IT'S CALLED RIO
GRANDE CITY.
THEY HAD 1107 PEOPLE COME ACROSS
FROM MIDNIGHT UNTIL 4:00 P.M.
THE NEXT DAY.
THAT WAS JUST ONE GROUP OVER TWO
SHIFTS, LAWRENCE.
AND THEY HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
I MEAN, LITERALLY YOU HAVE
EVERYBODY FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO BORDER AGENCIES TO FEDERAL
AGENCIES SAYING THAT THESE ARE
NUMBERS THEY HAVE NEVER SEEN IN
THEIR ENTIRE CAREERS SPANNING
10, 20, 30, 40 YEARS.
ONE THING THAT I THINK IS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND IS THAT ALL THIS DOES
IS DEFINE THE BORDER OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW, HUMAN MIGRATION AND
THE HUMANITARIAN ASPECT OF THIS.
IT LEAVES OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
AND BORDER SECURITY OUT OF THE
EQUATION.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANTS.
BECAUSE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
CAN CHANGE ALL OF THIS LITERALLY
LIKE THAT WITH A NAP OF THEIR
FINGERS.
THEY CHANGED THE POLICIES AND
THEY CAN STOP THE FLOW.
SO WHAT YOU KNOW FROM THAT IS
THAT THEY ARE -- THEY ARE NOT
DEFINING THE NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT.
THEY ARE NOT COUNTERING THE
NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT.
AND THEY ARE NOT BEING HONEST
ABOUT THE NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT.
SO WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
I MEAN, THIS -- WHAT THEY ARE
DOING IS BY DESIGN.
THIS IS A RESULT OF NO ACTION.
THIS IS A RESULT OF THE ACTIONS
THAT THEY TOOK SO IT'S THE
OUTCOME THEY PLANNED FOR.
IT'S THE OUTCOME THEY
IMPLEMENTED AND IT'S THE OUTCOME
THAT THEY ARE SUSTAINING.
SO THE REAL QUESTION IS HOW DOES
THIS BENEFIT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE THEY HAVE
OBVIOUSLY MADE A CALCULATION
THAT IT DOES.
>> Lawrence: BECAUSE THEY RAN ON
THIS.
THE MEDIA THEN PUSHED BACK.
HE GOT ELECTED ON THIS.
AND NOW THEY ARE STARTING TO
DROP IN THE POLLS.
SO, I HAVE GOT TO ASK YOU THIS,
STEPHEN MILLER.
DO THEY PIVOT?
BECAUSE WE SEE THE ONLY TIME
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
STARTS TO HAVE SOME TYPE OF
PIVOT IS WHEN THE POLLING COMES
IN AND THEY START TO DROP.
>> TRAGICALLY I DON'T THINK THEY
ARE GOING TO CHANGE COURSE ON
THE BORDER AND THE REASON FOR
THAT IS BECAUSE THE LEFT IS
PLAYING THE LONG GAME ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
THEIR VIEW IS THAT ADDING
MILLIONS OF ILLEGAL MIGRANTS TO
THE COUNTRY IS GOING TO PUSH THE
POLITICS OF THIS COUNTRY FURTHER
LEFT.
AND SO FOR THE SAKE OF THAT
GOAL, THEY ARE WILLING TO DROP
IN THE POLLS TO PAY A PRICE THIS
HAS BEEN AND REMAINS THEIR
HIGHEST PRIORITY.
LOOK, FOR EXAMPLE, AT THE BUDGET
RECONCILIATION BILL THAT THEY
ARE PLANNING ON PASSING, THE
$3.5 TRILLION ONE WE HAVE HEARD
SO MUCH ABOUT.
THEY ARE PLANNING ON INCLUDING
AMNESTY IN THERE.
THAT MEANS CITIZENSHIP AND
VOTING RIGHTS FOR WHO?
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
SO, REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO MAKE THE CASE TO MIDTERM
VOTERS THAT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS PUTTING THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF YOU, YOUR FAMILY,
AND THE WHOLE COUNTRY IN GRAVE
DANGER.
I WILL MAKE ONE POINT ON THIS
THAT I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT.
AS BAD AS THE SITUATION IS IN
AFGHANISTAN, THE DEADLIEST
FOREIGN POLICY FAILURE BY FAR OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS THE
CRISIS ON OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE DRUGS, GANGS, AND CRIME WILL
CLAIM THOUSANDS OF LIVES IN
AMERICA THIS YEAR.
>> Lawrence: IT'S SO TRUE.
AND PEOPLE ARE DYING AS A RESULT
OF THOSE DEADLY DRUGS COMING
ACROSS.
SYNTHETIC DRUGS IS GOING TO KILL
PEOPLE.
LARA, I HAVE TALKED TO SOME OF
MY SOURCES ON THE GROUND FROM
WHEN I WAS ON THE BORDER.
THE MORALE IS LOW.
WHAT ARE YOU HEARING FROM THOSE
BORDER AGENTS?
I HEAR SOME ARE JUST WALKING OFF
THE JOB.
THEY CAN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE.
>> WELL, THE BORDER AGENTS HAVE
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS
AND, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY, THEY
ARE COMPLETELY AND UTTERLY
OVERWHELMED.
THEY KNOW BECAUSE THE PLANNING
STARTED VERY EARLY ON LAST YEAR
AFTER THE ELECTION.
SO THEY KNOW THAT THIS WAS PUT
INTO PLACE DELIBERATELY.
AND WHAT, YOU KNOW, WHAT THEY
ARE STARTING TO ASK NOW IS
QUESTIONS LIKE HOW DOES THE
FAILURE OF THE U.S. IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM AND THE FAILURE OF THE
SOUTHERN BORDER HOW DOES THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION STEVEN
IS RIGHT ABOUT PLAYINGS THE LONG
GAME.
IT'S THE SAME THING WHEN IT
COMES TO DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
SADLY, IT'S THE SAME THING WHEN
IT COMES TO THE FENTANYL WHICH
IS OVER 9,000 POUNDS ALREADY
THIS FISCAL YEAR AND NOT DONE.
LAST FISCAL YEAR WAS A RECORD
AND IT ONLY 4700-POUND.
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
EXPONENTIALLY INCREASING WHAT IS
A NATIONAL SECURITY THREVMENT IT
COSTS THIS COUNTRY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BECAUSE, WHEN YOU HAVE
THE WHOLE COMMUNITIES OVERDOES
AND ADDICTED THEN THEY ARE NOT
PAYING TAXES, THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO WORK.
THEY ARE NOT JOINING THE
MILITARY.
THEY ARE NOT STAYING IN SCHOOL.
IT THEIR CHILDREN ARE NOTIOING
UP IN STABLE MOMMY'S HOMES.
THERE IS ALL THESE KNOCK DOWN
EFFECTS.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT THE
MEXICAN CARTELS ARE DOING.
THIS THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> WITH AN OPEN BORDER THAT IS
THAT THEY ARE THE NUMBER ONE
BENEFICIARIES OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S OPEN BORDER.
AND THEY ARE ALSO IN A STRATEGIC
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CHINESE.
SO, YOU KNOW, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THEY KNOW
PERFECTLY WELL WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE, AND IF THEY WANTED TO
CHANGE IT, THEY WOULD.
AND THEY COULD.
THE OTHER PART OF THIS,
LAWRENCE, IS WHY ARE THEY MOVING
CHILDREN FROM THE BORDER?
WHY ARE THEY MOVING THEM IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT?
WHY ARE THEY MOVING THEM IN --
UNDER THE COVER OF DARKNESS?
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE CITIES
WHERE THEY ARE GOING, AND YOU
ACTUALLY OVERLAY THAT WITH COVID
CASES, SPIKES IN COVID CASES
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WORKING ON THIS
THAT I HAVE SPOKEN TO WHO SAY
THAT THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
CORRELATION.
SO YOU'RE EXPORTING COVID ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY UNDER COVER OF
DARKNESS IN ORDER TO CHANGE THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THIS COUNTRY AND
LET'S NOT FORGET THE LAST POINT?
LOOK AT ALL THE MEDIA HEADLINES
ABOUT THE CENSUS OVER THE LAST
FEW DAYS.
YOU KNOW, WHICH WERE ALL ABOUT
OH, AMERICA'S WHITE POPULATION
IS DOWN.
THE CENSUS CONFIRMS IT.
THE FUTURE OF AMERICA IS
DIVERSE.
YEAH, IT SURE IS YOU KNOW THAT
WHEN YOU ARE MAKING SURE THAT IT
IS AS DIVERSE AS YOU WANT IT TO
BE.
>> Lawrence: I'M JUST WONDERING
WHERE ALL THE ELECTED OFFICIALS
THAT WERE CRYING AT THE BORDER
ABOUT THE KIDS' SAFETY, I MEAN,
THEY ARE PARKING THESE KIDS AND
PARENTS AND THEY ARE LIKE
SARDINES AND NO ONE SAYS
ANYTHING ABOUT IT WITHIN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
NO AOC.
NO SQUAD.
NO NANCY PELOSI.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE KAMALA
HARRIS IS.
THEY KEEP GIVING HER JOB AFTER
JOB AND SHE DOES ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING.
IF REPUBLICANS GET BACK IN POWER
AND D